you post a lot of video of yourself
training at very motivational you posted
one video that I have to ask you about
which it looks like you're just getting
punched in the stomach let's show the
video and then I'll ask you what this is
all about let's take a look true AB test
ok I think why I could do what I figured
what if I did tests on you mean iPod
[Applause]
let me go for it go no come on don't
and II wanted to crack at me - why did
you rap him
I don't want to feel left out I mean
you're gonna punch him I want you wait
you're right punch that was great why I
mean I wasn't gonna be weak on you no no
no I found it erotic hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please